Now let's look at the solution for our MOVZ MOVN Performance Quiz.
The fact that this branch is 50% taken means that on average,
we execute half of the time three instructions and
half of the time two instructions. So if we perfectly predict this,
we will be executing 2.5 instructions on average per execution of this code.
In contrast here, we get four instructions, but we cannot have mis-predictions.
However, here we have our misprediction rate times a 30 instruction penalty.
And if the misprediction is such that these two are equal, then this would be
equal to 4. Then, our x, the misprediction rate, needs to be 4 minus 2.5,
leaves us with 1.5 instructions worth of advantage here.
And 30 instructions worth of disadvantage if we mispredict. So in order for
them to balance, the misprediction rate needs to be 0.05, which amounts to 5%.
So pretty much, if the prediction accuracy is below 95%, then if
converted code is better. If the prediction accuracy in this case is above 95%,
then the original code is better. If the misprediction accuracy is exactly 95%,
then the two have equal performance.